oh hi everybody I'm Chris color and I'm
never going to be able to get to sleep
again today's very special episode of
Game life we're down here one of my
favorite places in san francisco the
musee mechanique on Fisherman's Wharf
it's an amazing collection of penny
arcade machines from the 1930s and 1940s
and it's what people used to blow their
pocket change on before we had video
games
now this isn't the only opium den in San
Francisco but it is the only one that
costs a quarter mechanical amusements
like this weren't interactive you just
put your money in and watch these little
guys go for a few seconds but what's
interesting is how many of them revolved
around drug abuse sex violence and
alcohol really proving the popular
entertainment has always pushed the
boundaries of decent behavior
I
hahaha man you know watching jolly jack
laughs is drunken mechanical ass off is
all well and good for me penny arcade's
are all about the games you know using
just a little bit of electricity and a
whole lot of mechanical ingenuity penny
arcade's were able to play all kinds of
different games from boxing to baseball
and even the very first first-person
shooters
you
pinball that destroyer of youth that
Corrupter of children's lives you know
in a lot of states pinball was actually
illegal for a good long time because it
was considered to be a game of chance
now eventually courts ruled the flippers
and bumpers made it a game of skill but
because it was considered to contribute
to the delinquency of minors minors were
still forbidden by law to operate
pinball machines
the musee mechanique is also home to
some of the very first video games and
the very first controversial video game
back in the 70s company called exedy
released death race which ignited a
firestorm when it was discovered that
its gameplay consisted entirely of
driving a car around and running over
pedestrians how times have changed
whoa I'm going to need some alone time
with this muta scope and that means we
have to leave the musee mechanique now
we've had a great time you played almost
all the machines except there's one
thing we haven't done which is press
this big red but nothing bad
you